Hi, I'm John Goodman, Grizzled Show Business Veteran, and you're listening to Smartless. I was almost just a little bit late today because I may have just had like one of my first sessions, definitely first half dozen. You can't count them on one hand the amount of times I've gone on Instagram. You guys are familiar with this? Yes, I've heard of this. Oh my God, this is so good. This is my dream come true, you describing Instagram. So yes, so I'm looking, watching a video on it, right?
嗨，我是约翰·古德曼，一位饱经沧桑的演艺界老兵，你现在收听的是Smartless。我今天差点就迟到了，因为我刚刚可能经历了我的第一次，绝对是前六次之一的体验。你都数不过来我到底用过多少次Instagram。你们对这个熟悉吗？是的，我听说过这个。哦天哪，这太棒了。这简直是我的梦想成真，你竟然在描述Instagram。所以，是的，我当时在看，在上面看视频，对吧？
It's a small... Keep going, keep going. Funny stuff is happening, people are falling and hurting themselves. And then my thumb accidentally hits the screen and it disappears, goes up, and there's another one right underneath it. That's right. It's similar, but then, I don't know,
这是一个小……继续，继续。有趣的事情正在发生，人们在摔倒，在伤害自己。然后我的拇指不小心按到了屏幕，它就消失了，往上一滑，紧接着又出现了一个。没错。这很类似，不过然后，我不知道，
so I did it again and then I'm like, then it's like some sort of a sports thing and then someone's selling me something. Anyway, I don't think it's Instamatic or instantaneous. I think it's insta-matic or instantaneous. I think it's insta-gram. Instagram. And you don't usually go on there? What is it? You don't usually go on there. What is it? Can I just, was that just you describing using Instagram? Yeah, I think so you know what I'm talking about. You've been there.
所以我又试了一次，然后我想，接下来就像是什么体育节目，然后有人在向我推销东西。总之，我不觉得它叫Instamatic或者instantaneous。我觉得它叫insta-matic或者instantaneous。我觉得它叫insta-gram。Instagram。你平时不去那上面看吗？那是什么？你平时不去那上面看。那是什么？我能问一下，刚才那真的是你在描述怎么用Instagram吗？对，我想是的，你知道我在说什么。你去过那儿。
So you really don't go on Well, we're not alone. You don't usually go on there, Jason. No, but I get it now. Pete, you can sit there and I did what I thought was gonna be five minutes and all of a sudden my alarm went off to get to the computer to start this. I was like, oh, fuck, good thing I set an alarm.
所以你真的不去……好吧，我们并不孤单。你平时也不去那上面，杰森。不，但我现在懂了。皮特，你可以坐在那儿，我本以为只用五分钟，结果突然我的闹钟响了，提醒我该去电脑前开始录制了。当时我想，噢，操，幸好我设置了闹钟。
It's the demise of our whole institution. It's everything. Now, Sean and I send each other videos that we think are funny. Yes. And it's really easy to do. Would you like in on that? And that's a funny way to communicate as well. Oh, so if I see something on Instagram that I like,
这是我们整个体制的消亡。这就是一切。现在，肖恩和我经常互相发送我们觉得有趣的视频。是的。而且这做起来非常简单。你想加入吗？这也是一种很有趣的交流方式。哦，所以如果我在Instagram上看到我喜欢的东西，
I could sort of like send that to you. There's like a little thing I can click. There's an icon there and you can hit it. And then if we're all following each other, you can send it to one of us and then we go like, uh-huh, that's so funny because it's true or whatever. Right, or yeah, or saw it, thanks old man. Yeah, exactly.
我可以把它发给你。上面好像有个小东西我可以点。那里有个图标，你点一下就行。然后如果我们都互相关注的话，你就可以把它发给我们中的某个人，然后我们就会说，“啊哈，太搞笑了，因为这很真实”或者诸如此类的话。对，或者，是的，或者“看到了，谢谢老头子”。对，没错。
Wait, so now we can send you videos and you'll actually watch them? Yes, I think I will. I might not, oh, but you know what I don't do is if you send me a video that when I click on it says, oh, the person whose video this is will know that you are watching it, then I don't click on those.
等等，所以现在我们可以给你发视频，而且你真的会看？对，我想我会的。我可能不会，哦，但你知道我不会做什么吗？如果你给我发了一个视频，当我点开时上面写着“哦，这个视频的主人会知道你在看”，那我就不会点开那些。
What does that mean? Does that mean the person's a private? Nobody knows what you're looking at unless you like it. No, like when Amanda sends me something and I gotta click, I have to say that it's, they're gonna see that it's me. No, that's just a phone call. Oh.
这是什么意思？这意思是发视频的人是个私密账号？没人知道你在看什么，除非你点赞。不，就像阿曼达发给我什么东西时，我得点进去，我得确认，他们会看到是我看的。不，那只是个电话。哦。
I don't know, but this is, listen, this stuff, this is... And it's all here on one of these. You guys have one of these phones? This is, uh, with the pictures on the front of it? This is the beginning of the end. This is it. Because I just got rid of the one that closes, you know. It kind of looks like a Pac-Man. By the way, this is our generation equivalent of when our dads used to say,
我不知道，但是这个，听着，这东西……而且这一切都在这其中一个上面。你们都有这种手机吗？就是正面有照片的那种？这是一切的结束的开始。就是这样。因为我刚刚扔掉了那种可以合上的手机，你知道的。它看起来有点像吃豆人。顺便说一句，这相当于我们这一代人当年听到老爸们说：
I saw this thing in the paper today. Or on the TV. Right. On the TV. Wait, that was a picture of Maple, and I saw her for her birthday. I saw Maple last night. Look at that. She just turned 12.
“我今天在报纸上看到了这个。”或者在电视上。对。在电视上。等等，那是梅普尔的照片，我为了她的生日见到了她。我昨晚见到梅普尔了。你看那个。她刚刚满12岁。
I know. Scotty and I got her some beads that she can wear on her wrist, and we got her a little leather-bound thing that she can draw in, because she's such a good drawer. She's incredible. She's amazing. She's an amazing artist. And, and an incredible athlete. Yes, amazing.
我知道。斯科蒂和我给她买了一些可以戴在手腕上的珠子，我们还给她买了一个可以涂鸦的小皮面笔记本，因为她太会画画了。她画得棒极了。她太惊艳了。她是个出色的艺术家。而且，还是个了不起的运动员。是的，太棒了。
She's so good. She's been kicking ass. They beat another big team, you know, that you were there at the game. She told me who they beat the other night, and I was like, no way. No, I know. It's crazy. The Celtics. Did I already bore you guys with the fact that it was the boss in Celtics? Yeah, so she's in sixth grade and she plays on the boys team because she's such a badass. It's the first time in the history of the school that a girl's ever played
她太厉害了。她一直在大杀四方。他们击败了另一个大球队，你知道的，你当时就在比赛现场。她前几天告诉我他们击败了谁，我都惊呆了，心想“不会吧”。不，我知道。太疯狂了。凯尔特人队。我刚才是不是已经跟你们唠叨过击败凯尔特人队这事了？对，所以她现在读六年级，而且她在男孩队打球，因为她是个狠角色。这是该校历史上第一次有女孩在
on the boys team. It's so rad. I know. I just, I love her. It's so wild, Jason. It's nighttime. It's seven o'clock. Are you, you're getting sleepy or? Just about, you know, I had a long day of work, but this is the highlight of my day. Look at you two, you know?
男孩队打球。太酷了。我知道。我就是，我太喜欢她了。太疯狂了，杰森。现在是晚上了。已经七点了。你，你是开始犯困了吗？差不多吧，你知道的，我今天工作了一整天，但这（节目）是我一天中的高潮。看看你们两个，你知道的？
Please don't fuck it up with a shit guest, Arnett. You know what, if this is a terrible, let's just end it here. I can't wait, I'm so glad. I can't wait for you to eat this shit. You're eating these words, you're moments away from eating, you're gonna be so embarrassed. You're gonna be so embarrassed. You're gonna be, you're gonna bow down
阿纳特，请别找个烂嘉宾把这搞砸了。你知道吗，如果这是一个糟糕的节目，我们就在这儿结束吧。我等不及了，我太高兴了。我等不及看你吃瘪了。你要把刚才的话吞下去，你马上就要吃瘪了，你会觉得超级尴尬。你会觉得超级尴尬。你会，你会向
to the power of this dude. Because- Want one of these first? Let's do a dad joke first and then we're gonna make him bow down. One dad joke, go ahead, Sean. It's been too long already. I can't find my Gone In 60 Seconds DVD.
这家伙的实力顶礼膜拜。因为——先来个这个吗？我们先讲个冷笑话，然后我们要让他顶礼膜拜。讲一个冷笑话吧，肖恩。已经耽误够久了。我找不到我的《极速60秒》DVD了。
It was here a minute ago. Okay, all right, so here we go. We've wasted this person's time and he deserves so much more respect than that. Well, we'll see. And Jason, I am so sad because this is a guy who's been doing it for a long time at the highest level. He's been nominated for, I think he's won an Emmy nominated for seven times Golden Globe nominated four times, like every, he's been just nominated and won everything. We just apologize now. I'll just start with an apology. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no But like really until you're fired up to it's making influence on my life Yeah, and you guys know because I have on the show used them consistently as
它刚才还在这儿呢。好吧，好吧，那我们开始吧。我们已经浪费了这位嘉宾的时间，他理应得到更多的尊重。好吧，我们走着瞧。杰森，我太难过了，因为这家伙长期以来一直在最高水平上进行创作。他曾获得过，我觉得他获得过艾美奖提名，获得过七次金球奖提名，还有四次提名，就像所有，他简直获得过所有奖项的提名并赢过一切。我们现在就道歉吧。我直接从道歉开始。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不情愿，直到你真正被它激发，它正在对我的生活产生影响。是的，你们也知道，因为我在节目中一直把他们作为
The gold standard I talked about people being being okay being in bad movies But always being good and I he is always my example as you guys know of the guy who's never turned into bad Performance and but it's been a lot of bad movies We got one of the things that I love about him most that he and I have in common is that he said, you guys lost to a bunch of fucking nerds. Guys, it's the all time champ for me is John Goodman. Oh, I'm so sorry, Mr. Goodman. Hi, fellas.
黄金标准。我谈到过人们演烂片也无所谓，但总是能保持高水准。正如你们所知，他一直是我的榜样，他从来没有过糟糕的表演，尽管他演过很多烂片。我最喜欢他的一点，也是我和他共同的一点，他说过，你们输给了一群该死的书呆子。伙计们，对我来说历史最佳冠军就是约翰·古德曼。哦，非常抱歉，古德曼先生。嗨，伙计们。
I can't follow that. Johnny Goodman. Well done follow that. Johnny Goodman. Well done, Will. Mr. John Goodman. By the way, every word he just said is true. Every single thing you've ever done is phenomenal. I agree. Every performance.
我接不上这个。强尼·古德曼。干得好，接上了。强尼·古德曼。干得好，威尔。约翰·古德曼先生。顺便说一句，他刚才说的每一句话都是真的。你做过的每一件事都是惊艳绝伦的。我同意。每一个表演。
There's not a dud in the. Ah, ah, ah. It's true. Yeah. And always associated with good people. He does reference you quite a bit as the bar to jump over. It is true. John, at risk of embarrassing you further,
里面没有一个是烂片。啊，啊，啊。是真的。是的。而且总是和优秀的人合作。他确实经常提到你，把你作为衡量的高标准。确实如此。约翰，冒着让你更加尴尬的风险，
what a pleasure to meet you, and thank you for coming and doing this and joining us. No, my pleasure, thank you. It's America's favorite podcast. Thank you for welcoming me into your pod. This is cool. Well, I do use that, you often, and I'm sorry, again, at risk of embarrassing you,
能见到您真是荣幸，谢谢您能来参加并加入我们。不，我的荣幸，谢谢你们。这是全美最受欢迎的播客。谢谢你们欢迎我加入你们的播客。这太酷了。我确实用过那个，你经常，而且我很抱歉，再次冒着让你尴尬的风险，
as the sort of the the gold standard of someone who's always good and never turns into bad performance and I've been such a fan of yours for such a long time and you've done so many different things and you've crossed you've done comedy in you know you've done sitcoms multiple really fantastic sitcoms like the old-school standard like like multi cams like with an audience that is just and to do that pull it off Well, sorry Sean to pull it off well Best job in the world the best job in the world, but then you've had an incredible career in film But you started in theater is where I'm driving it
把你当作那种黄金标准，一个总是表现出色、从不奉献烂演技的人。我是你长久以来的超级粉丝，你做过这么多不同的尝试，你跨界演过喜剧，你知道的，你演过情景喜剧，很多真正棒极了的情景喜剧，就像老派标准那种，像多机位带现场观众的，而且能演好，能把这演好——抱歉，肖恩——能把这演好。世上最好的工作，世上最好的工作。但接着你在电影界也有了不可思议的职业生涯。不过你最初是从戏剧开始的，这是我要引入的话题。
This is where we'll driving at. Oh, here comes Sean. Here comes John. This is where Will and I just sit back. So I want to hear about how, what that start was like for you, Mr. Goodman, because I don't know the story and how you got, and what your journey was. I had nowhere else to go. Excellent, next question. I sabotaged my own education.
这就是我们要引入的话题。哦，肖恩来了。约翰来了。这就是我和威尔只能坐在一旁听的时候了。所以我想听听你的起点是怎样的，古德曼先生，因为我不知道这个故事，不知道你是如何开始的，你的心路历程是怎样的。我当时无处可去。太棒了，下一个问题。我毁了自己的学业。
The only time I got lit up was doing plays, and I decided to make that my major since I was inches from being thrown out of school. Really? Everything took off after that, and as soon as I found out how wonderful it can be, then I started to want to learn history, English, whatever I needed to pull out of my bag of tricks
我唯一能来劲的时候就是排演话剧，既然我被开除只差一步之遥，我决定把这个作为我的主修专业。真的吗？从那以后一切都起飞了，一旦我发现这有多么美妙，我便开始想要学习历史、英语，以及任何我需要在扮演角色时从百宝箱里拿出来用的东西。
when performing a role. Oh wow, so that you could stay in school and stay a part of the theater department. Yeah. Oh wow. That's pretty cool. Where was that? Where was that?
哦，哇，这样你就能留在学校，继续留在戏剧系了。对。哦，哇。这太酷了。那是哪里？那是哪里？
So you were in school, were you in Missouri? Is that right? It was called Southwest Missouri State University. Now it's called Missouri State University. But then you moved to New York. Is that true? Is that how that went? That is true.
所以你当时在上学，你在密苏里州？是这样吗？它当时叫西南密苏里州立大学。现在叫密苏里州立大学。但后来你搬到了纽约。是真的吗？事情是这样的吗？千真万确。
That took the Amtrak from St. Louis to New York in August of 1975. Holy shit. And did you have a destiny, other than the city, were you like, I'm gonna go do this, or were you just like, I'm rolling the dice here? I was a frightened hick. The main thing I wanted to do was take classes
我于1975年8月坐着美铁（Amtrak）从圣路易斯来到了纽约。操。那你当时有明确的目标吗，除了这座城市之外，你是那种“我要去大干一场”的心态，还是说“我只是去那里碰碰运气”？我当时是个被吓坏的乡巴佬。我最想做的事情是去上
with Uta Hagen and get into the actor's studio and learn some more. And did you get in there? I did not, I left about a month and a half later doing a non-equity dinner theater version of 1776. What dinner theater? The Lacomedia Dinner Playhouse in Springboro, Ohio. I worked at Pheasant Run Dinner Theater in St. Charles, Illinois. Oh, okay. What was your first-ever comedy and dinner playhouse in Springboro, Ohio?
乌塔·哈根（Uta Hagen）的表演课，进入演员工作室学点更多东西。那你进去了吗？没有，我大概一个半月后就离开了，去参加了一个非演员工会（non-equity）的餐剧剧院版《1776》的演出。什么餐剧剧院？俄亥俄州斯普林伯勒的拉孔迪亚晚餐剧场（Lacomedia Dinner Playhouse）。我在伊利诺伊州圣查尔斯的野鸡跑晚餐剧场（Pheasant Run Dinner Theater）工作过。哦，好吧。你在俄亥俄州斯普林伯勒的第一个喜剧餐剧剧院是什么？
I worked at Pheasant Run Dinner Theater in St. Charles, Illinois. Oh, okay. Yeah, which I just found out Ben Stiller's parents did summer stock there. Oh, right, yeah. Summer chicken stock, I guess, because it's dinner theater.
我在伊利诺伊州圣查尔斯的野鸡跑晚餐剧场工作过。哦，好吧。是的，我最近才发现本·斯蒂勒的父母曾在那里进行过夏季驻场演出。哦，对，是的。大概是夏季鸡肉驻场演出吧，因为那是晚餐剧院。
There we go. So dinner theater is what it sounds like, correct? You sit there, you're at your tables, and they serve you the whole thing while the play's going on, and the actors are... How dare they make noise. Well, this is gonna say... Oh, you got the glasses clanking in the porch door. Yeah, and the fucking...
这就对了。所以晚餐剧院就像听起来的那样，对吧？你坐在那儿，坐在桌子旁，他们在戏剧上演的同时把整顿饭端上来，而演员们……他们怎么敢制造噪音。好吧，这就要说了……哦，你会听到玻璃杯在盘子上碰撞的声音。对，还有他妈的……
People getting lit. Yeah, getting lit, and whistling the waiter over because the shit's not right, and... And they put the tables right up to the edge of the stage. So then I was playing Tommy Gilles in the Music Man and I was doing something, fell right on top of one of the tables and had to keep going.
人们喝嗨了。对，喝嗨了，然后吹口哨把服务员叫过来，因为东西不对劲，而且……他们把桌子直接摆到了舞台边缘。所以当时我在《音乐人》（The Music Man）里扮演汤米·吉尔斯（Tommy Gilles），正演着呢，直接摔到了一张桌子上，然后还必须硬着头皮演下去。
It was so ridiculous. For the God. Just living your dream with a bunch of pasta sauce in your pants. My buddy Hackett. I mean, was there ever a time when you're on stage and you're like, oh man, that smells pretty good down there. You got primer.
太荒谬了。我的天。一边实现着你的梦想，一边裤子里塞满了意大利面酱。我的哥们哈克特。我是说，有没有那么一次，你在舞台上心想：哦，天哪，下面闻起来挺香啊。你当时涂了底漆。
I couldn't get hired for their next shows, but my girlfriend did. So I went down there just to get out of New York and work as a waiter in the dinner theater. Wow, that's amazing. For the summer, but I cut the grass. I did all kinds of odd jobs and made enough money to pay off my student loans that summer.
我没能被他们的下一部剧雇用，但我女朋友被录用了。所以我去那里只是为了离开纽约，顺便在晚餐剧院里当个服务员。哇，那太惊人了。为了过夏天，但我还负责割草。我做了各种零工，那个夏天赚够了钱把学生贷款全还清了。
Wow. So, sorry, Sean, so New York was a total wipeout, and so you... No, not at all. I just, I left, it was a horrible winter, and I was broke, and I couldn't get arrested as a waiter or anything else. I got one night's work as a bouncer at a club called the Adam's Apple
哇。所以，抱歉，肖恩，所以纽约之旅完全是一败涂地，然后你……不，完全没有。我只是，我离开了，那是糟糕的一个冬天，我身无分文，当服务员或其他任何工作都混不下去。我有天晚上在一家叫“亚当的苹果”的俱乐部当了一晚上的保镖，
and they had this German head bouncer who was telling us how to rip guys' mouths open when you got their head down on the curve and then you stomp the back of their head and their teeth come out. Jesus. Sure. I Jesus, of course. Sure. I said, check please.
当时有个德国领班保镖在教我们怎么把别人的嘴撕开，当把他们的头按在路边石上时，然后用力踩他们的后脑勺，他们的牙齿就会飞出来。耶稣啊。当然。我——耶稣啊，当然。当然。我说，买单，谢谢。
Yeah, I had to show up the next day. So then where did you go at that? That's the only job I had in the city. So then it does sound like New York, it wasn't really bearing a lot of fruit. Well, it was also, at the time, it was Ford to City, drop dead, they were defaulting on their loans. The City was just going to hell.
对，我第二天就没再去上班。那接下来你去了哪里？那是我在城里唯一做过的工作。所以听起来纽约确实没带来什么成果。嗯，当时的情况是，（纽约市正处于）“福特对城市说：去死吧”，他们正在拖欠贷款。这座城市简直在走向地狱。
The subways were terrifying, the graffiti, all the stuff. And I was a kid from the suburbs. But I was determined to live there because I dug it. So you left for a little bit, went to Ohio, and then you came back to New York? Yeah, I came back and then I got my card about like a month after that. Your equity card or SAG card?
地铁让人毛骨悚然，涂鸦，各种乱七八糟的事。而我只是个来自郊区的孩子。但我决心留在那里，因为我喜欢那儿。所以你离开了一会儿，去了俄亥俄州，然后又回到了纽约？对，我回去了，大约一个月后我就拿到了工会会员证。你的演员工会卡（Equity card）还是演员工会SAG卡？
Yeah, my equity card doing a bus and truck of the Robber Bridegroom. Oh my God, that is so, I know that. And so how old were you? You were about 20? What, 20? Yeah, 23, 24. Any other options available to you at that moment,
对，是通过参演音乐剧《强盗新郎》（The Robber Bridegroom）的巡演拿到了我的演员工会卡。天哪，我知道那个。那你当时多大？你大概20岁？什么，20岁？对，23、24岁。当时还有什么其他选择摆在你面前吗，
either practically or just sort of emotionally? Like were you attracted to anything else? Could you have taken a fork in the road and been something else at that moment? No, I had... The way I look back on it now, it unfolds itself like it was a calling. Yeah. I mean, I used to get kicked out of,
无论是现实层面上还是某种情感层面上？比如你还被其他什么东西吸引吗？当时有没有可能在人生的十字路口转向别的行业？没有，我……如今回想起来，它就像是一个天职一样自然而然地展开了。是的。我是说，我以前经常被，
when I'd get kicked out of a class, they'd send me to the library and I would sit there and read plays. And I'm like, you know, 14, 15 years old. I have no idea why. Yeah. Was anybody in your family doing that? Like was it, no.
每当被赶出课堂时，老师就会把我送到图书馆，我就会坐在那里读剧本。那时我大概14、15岁。我完全不知道为什么。是的。你家里有人从事这行吗？比如，没有。
My brother was a fan of theater, he's a bit older than me. And we'd go into Clayton, Missouri, pick up the New York Times every Sunday, literally, weighed a ton back then. And I would go to the Arts and Leisure, basically to look at the Hirschfield cartoons. And then I'd just start following what shows were up. I had no idea why.
我哥哥是个戏剧迷，他比我大一点。我们会去密苏里州克莱顿，每周日 literalmente（字面意义上）去买《纽约时报》，当时那报纸拿起来重得要命。我会直奔艺术与休闲版块，基本上就是为了看赫希菲尔德（Hirschfeld）的漫画。然后我就会开始关注有哪些剧目在上映。我根本不知道为什么。
You just enjoyed it. Yeah. Why were you getting kicked out of class? Were you just running your mouth and you wanted to perform and get attention? I had to have attention. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, learning was, learning bad, attention good. Yeah, I had the have attention. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, learning was, learning bad, attention good.
你只是享受其中。是的。你当时为什么会被赶出课堂？是因为你顶嘴，还是你想表现自己以博取关注？我必须得到关注。对，没错。对，学习这事儿——学习坏，关注好。对，我必须得到关注。对，没错。对，学习这事儿——学习坏，关注好。
Yeah, I had the same problem. So then, John, so then New York, you stuck it out there and things really started to pick up traction or was the big break out in Los Angeles or somewhere in between? I had a series of little breaks. When I got back from the tour, I had one time, I had a bunch of pictures,
我也有同样的问题。那么，约翰，你在纽约坚持了下来，事情真的开始有了起色，还是说你的大突破是在洛杉矶或介于两者之间的某个地方？我经历了一系列的小突破。巡演回来后，有一次，我把一堆照片、
you know, resumes, stapled them all together, and in desperation I was sending them out to theaters. One guy at Great Advertising picked up my picture, called me in, I got the gig, and he set me up with commercial agents. And then I couldn't not get him for some reason. I just, I've been goofing off. I've been goofing on him my whole life.
简历用订书机订在一起，在绝望中把它们寄给了各大剧院。格雷广告公司（Great Advertising）的一个人挑中了我的照片，把我叫去面试，我拿到了这份工作，然后他把我介绍给了一些广告经纪人。不知为什么，我接广告接到手软。我这一生都在拿这事开玩笑。
Well, it's also kind of like the, like I speak on behalf of the four of us. If you can't do anything else, you have to make this work. Yeah. You know what I mean? You gotta pay the bills at least. Yeah. But by that time I was hanging out with a lot of like real, this work. Yeah. You know what I mean? And you gotta pay the bills at least. Yeah. So it's probably.
不过这也是那种，我代表我们四个人说句公道话。如果你干不了别的，你就必须把这事搞出名堂。对。你知道我的意思吗？你至少得付得起账单。对。但到那个时候，我已经和很多真正……干这行。对。你知道我的意思吗？而且你至少得付得起账单。对。所以可能。
By that time I was hanging out with a lot of real actors at a place up on the west side and I got to hate myself for doing commercials. I was all screwed up and I was really getting into drinking at the time. And I resented doing commercials because other guys were doing what I thought was real work.
到那个时候，我和西区的一群真正的演员混在一起，我开始痛恨自己拍广告。我整个人都搞砸了，当时我开始酗酒。我很反感拍广告，因为其他人都在做我心目中真正的艺术工作。
Right. So I didn't care. I think that's why I got so many of them. Right, right, right. And I got a lot of them. And in defense of commercials, I do like commercials. I think Stanley Kubrick said they're the only form of the medium that you can actually acquire perfection
没错。所以我当时根本不在乎。我想这就是为什么我能接到那么多广告的原因。对，对，对。而且我确实接了超级多。为广告辩护一下，我其实挺喜欢广告的。我想斯坦利·库布里克（Stanley Kubrick）曾说过，广告是唯一能真正达到完美的媒介形式，
because they're just 30 seconds and they're very intricately of the medium where you can actually acquire perfection because they're just 30 seconds and they're very intricately made nowadays. Especially. The lighting alone, man, would take forever to set up and it had to be just right and the product just right. And we will be right back. Thank you to Macy's for supporting this episode of Smart List.
因为它们只有30秒，而且制作极其精细。是的，是唯一能真正达到完美形式的媒介，因为它们只有30秒，而且现在的制作非常精细。尤其是。单是打光，伙计，就要花好长时间来布置，而且必须恰到好处，产品也必须完美无缺。我们马上回来。感谢梅西百货（Macy's）对本期Smart Less的支持。
Father's Day is June 16th and if you're not sure where to get Dad, let Macy's help you find something special using their gift finder. Macy's offers the ultimate gift guide to make selecting something special incredibly easy. Whether Dad's the kind of guy who prides himself on his grilling skills, that perfect swing on the golf course, or simply loves the latest tech gadgets, Macy's got you covered. Shop by price with amazing finds under $25, under $50, and over $100 for that extra touch of lux.
父亲节是6月16日，如果你不知道该送老爸什么礼物，让梅西百货的礼物查找器（gift finder）帮你寻找特别的东西吧。梅西百货提供了终极送礼指南，让挑选特别的礼物变得异常简单。无论老爸是那种以自己的烧烤手艺为傲的人、在球场上挥杆完美的运动健将，还是单纯热爱最新科技产品的达人，梅西百货都能满足你的需求。按价格选购，有惊喜好物低于25美元、低于50美元，以及超过100美元的奢华之选。
Or browse by category to pick up his new favorite cologne, a classic watch, or high quality leather goods. And the brands, we're talking Calvin Klein, Tommy Hilfiger, Polo Ralph Lauren, Columbia, the list goes on. Are you seeing something you would love for Father's Day on their website? If so, let me know what it's like to have a father. Head on over to macy's.com
或者按类别浏览，挑选他新的最爱古龙水、经典手表，或是高品质皮具。至于品牌，我们说的是Calvin Klein、Tommy Hilfiger、Polo Ralph Lauren、Columbia，名单不胜枚举。你在他们的网站上看到什么想作为父亲节礼物送人的东西了吗？如果是的话，告诉我拥有一个父亲是什么感觉。快去 macy's.com
gift finder to make Father's Day a memorable one. That's macy's.com gift finder. Hey, smartless listener, we're supported by Mint Mobile. My favorite spring cleaning takeaway is the post clean clarity you get, right? Wow, how have I been living like this? It's kind of like when you find out that you've been paying a fortune for wireless when Mint Mobile has phone plans for $15 a month when you purchase a three-month plan. Wow, how have I been affording this? It's time to switch to Mint Mobile and get unlimited talk, text, and data for $15 a month. Say bye to your overpriced wireless plans, jaw-dropping monthly bills, and unexpected overages.
gift finder，让这个父亲节令人难忘。网址是 macy's.com/gift finder。嘿，Smartless的听众朋友们，我们得到了Mint Mobile的支持。我最喜欢的春季大扫除心得是打扫完后那种神清气爽的清澈感，对吧？哇，我以前是怎么过这种日子的？这就有点像你发现自己一直在为无线网络花冤枉钱，而Mint Mobile的手机套餐购买三个月仅需每月15美元。哇，我以前是怎么负担得起这费用的？是时候切换到Mint Mobile，享受每月15美元的无限通话、短信和数据流量了。跟价格虚高的无线套餐、吓人的月账单以及意料之外的超额费用说再见吧。
Mint Mobile is here to rescue you with premium wireless plans starting at $15 a month. All plans come with high-speed data, and unlimited talk and text delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. To get this new customer offer and your new 3-month unlimited wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash smartlis. That's mintmobile.com slash smartlis. Cut your wireless bill to $15 a month at mintmobile.com slash smartless. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Gosh, this year has gone by so quickly so far, isn't it? It's already like we're almost like halfway through or something like that. But I still need to work on my patience. Ask my Betterhalf, Scotty. I'm impatient. I've been impatient my whole life. It's an asset, but it's also most of the time one of my downfalls. So it's something I need to work on because when life goes so fast, it's important to take a moment to celebrate your wins
Mint Mobile来拯救你了，优质无线套餐每月仅需15美元起。所有套餐都包含高速数据，并在全美最大的5G网络上提供无限通话和短信。要享受这个新客户优惠以及仅需每月15美元的3个月无限无线套餐，请访问 mintmobile.com/smartless。网址是 mintmobile.com/smartless。上 mintmobile.com/smartless，把你的话费降至每月15美元。本期节目由BetterHelp赞助。天哪，今年过得可真快啊，不是吗？感觉我们已经快过完半年了或者类似的时间。但我还是需要锻炼我的耐心。问问我的另一半，斯科蒂。我很没有耐心。我这辈子都很没有耐心。这是一个优点，但大多数时候也是我的致命弱点之一。所以这是我需要努力改进的地方，因为当生活过得如此之快时，花点时间庆祝你的胜利是非常重要的，
and just make adjustments for the rest of the year. Therapy can help you take stock of your progress and set achievable goals for the next six months. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire
并为接下来的日子做出调整。心理咨询可以帮你盘点进展，并为接下来的六个月设定可实现的目标。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线进行，旨在提供便利、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，
to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Take a moment. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.com slash smartlis. All right, back to the show. John, you had what Jason, you were getting so many what Jason likes to call you had at that time, it seems to me you had what Jason, you were getting so many, what Jason likes to call you had at that time, it seems to me you had a sexy indifference.
即可与持牌心理咨询师匹配，并且随时可以免费更换咨询师。花点时间。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartless，首月可享9折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com/smartless。好的，回到节目中。约翰，你当时拥有一种杰森——你当时拥有如此多的，用杰森喜欢的话来说，在你那个时期，在我看来你拥有了一种性感的冷漠。
You didn't care, you didn't go in there, you didn't want it too bad, and then you just kept getting him, and I know that that feeling, especially when you're younger, I remember thinking like, man, I'm not gonna read, and my first agent being like, it's pilot season, you're gonna read for some sitcoms.
你不在乎，你进到试镜房间时并没有表现得太渴望得到它，然后你却不断地接到角色。我知道那种感觉，尤其是当你年轻的时候，我记得当时想，天哪，我才不读呢，我的第一个经纪人说，现在是试播集（pilot）季，你要去为一些情景喜剧试读。
I'm like, sitcoms? How dare you? Are you out of your mind? I'll never do it. I'm sorry, I'm an artist. Yeah, and then all of a sudden I'm like so broke, and I'm like, fuck, I'll read for anything, please. You know what I mean?
我说，情景喜剧？你疯了吗？我绝不做这事。对不起，我是个艺术家。是的，然后突然之间我穷得叮当响，心想，操，我什么都愿意试读，求求你了。你知道我的意思吗？
Right. You know what though, Roseanne was so like, so theater. It was, a lot of sitcoms don't feel like theater and a lot of them do, which is what they should feel like. And Roseanne, to me, anytime I watched it, it was like, oh, I'm in New York watching a play every single time. That's a good point.
对。但你知道吗，罗斯anne（Roseanne）那部剧太……太具有戏剧感了。它确实如此，很多情景喜剧感觉不像戏剧，但很多又确实是，而那正是它们应该有的感觉。而《罗斯anne》对我来说，每次我看它的时候，都觉得，哦，我每一次就像是在纽约看一出话剧。这倒是个好观点。
Yeah. It was different for the time because the antidote to a lot of things like Dallas and Dynasty and all these rich folk things. And I think we hit a nerve. I know my nerves were beat. Does it go that far back? When was the, what was the year the pilot?
是的。这在当时很别树一帜，因为它是对许多诸如《豪门恩怨》（Dallas）、《王朝》（Dynasty）以及所有这些富人题材的反动。而且我认为我们触动了人们的神经。我知道我的神经被打动了。这要追溯到那么久以前吗？试播集是什么时候，哪一年拍的？
1987 I think, the pilot. Holy shit. I think I graduated or tried to graduate high school that year. I want to get to, I wanted to get to Roseanne because I really think, I mean, when you guys were doing it at its best, it was just unrivaled.
我想是1987年，试播集。操。我好像是那年从高中毕业或者尝试毕业的。我想聊聊，我一直想聊聊《罗斯anne》，因为我真的认为，当你们把这部剧做到巅峰时，简直是无可匹敌的。
I watched it every week. I was such a massive fan of what you guys did, all the work, the writing, everything about it, I thought was so good. How did that come into your orbit, John, at the time? Where were you at when that came around and you read that? I was out here for something. In LA?
我每周都看。我是你们所做的一切的超级粉丝，所有的工作、剧本，关于它的一切我都觉得太棒了。约翰，当时这个项目是怎么进入你的视角的？当它出现并且你读到剧本时，你身在何处？我当时为了别的事在那儿。在洛杉矶？
Yeah, it was either a movie or a commercial. And I got hip and ran into Corvette. I thought I was hot shit. I had a couple of bucks and I remember going to the audition in that Corvette. And I walked in, I didn't know much about her. I'd seen her in some Pizza Hut commercials. I'd seen a couple of clips and she was really good
对，要么是拍电影，要么是拍广告。我当时有点小名气，开着一辆克尔维特跑车。我觉得自己牛逼坏了。我手头攒了几个钱，我记得我是开着那辆克尔维特去试镜的。我走进去的时候，对她（罗斯anne）并不太了解。我曾在一些必胜客的广告里看过她。我看过几个片段，她在卡森秀（Carson show）上
like on the Carson show. And I walked in, it was very friendly and I read and I just, I knew I had the gig. Yeah. I just. Did you want that gig? Yeah. Where were you in your career at that point?
表现得真的很棒。我走进去，气氛非常友好，我试读了剧本，我当时就清楚我拿下这个工作了。对。我就是……你当时想要那份工作吗？对。那时你在演艺生涯处于什么阶段？
I was living out of suitcases all the time because I was just starting to get films. Yeah. Like starting in 1985, I was a book on a lot of movies. That was after Revenge of the Nerds. Yeah, that was shot in 83. Yeah. Yeah, that was shot in 83. When did you start your incredible collaboration with the Coen Brothers?
我当时一直提着行李箱到处飞，因为我刚开始有机会拍电影。是的。比如从1985年开始，我片约不断。那是《复仇者之征》（Revenge of the Nerds）之后。对，那是83年拍的。对。是的，那是83年拍的。你什么时候开始与科恩兄弟进行那次令人难以置信的合作的？
Was that during the run of Roseanne or was it after? No, it was before. It was in 1985. I just got a lead in a film that David Byrne directed. Really? Yeah, it was called True Stories. It's really interesting looking. Oh yeah, fuck, I wanna see that. And I was just really getting, you know, I'd show up,
那是在《罗斯anne》热播期间还是之后？不，是在那之前。那是1985年。我刚在一部由大卫·伯恩（David Byrne）执导的电影里演了主角。真的吗？对，那部电影叫《真事》（True Stories）。视觉效果非常有意思。哦对，操，我很想看那个。我当时真的开始，你知道的，我会去现场，
I'd go to Daly's, because I wanted to. What, when you were working with the Collins? Or with David Byrne? No, just before that, with David Byrne. And I was really getting into films. I wasn't as scared as I was. And I got called, I was in New York
我会去看毛片（Dailies），因为我想去。什么？当你在和科恩合作时？还是和大卫·伯恩？不，在那之前，和大卫·伯恩。我当时真的开始迷上电影了。我没有以前那么害怕了。我接到电话，我当时在纽约，
on a week off or something, anyway, I was in New York, they called me in for Raising Arizona. And we just sat down and goofed around for about an hour. Really? That was the audition. And then I read and left. I bet you felt like you got it. No, I didn't know but I never had a. But you sit in an office for an hour, I bet you felt like you got it. No, I didn't know but I'd never had a.
正好有一周假什么的，总之我在纽约，他们叫我去为《抚养亚利桑那》（Raising Arizona）试镜。我们只是坐下来瞎扯了一个小时左右。真的吗？那就是试镜。然后我读了剧本就走了。我敢说你当时觉得自己稳了。不，我不知道，但我从来没有过……但你在办公室坐了一个小时，我敢说你当时觉得自己肯定拿下了。不，我不知道，但我从来没有过……
But you sit in an office for an hour, like you gotta feel like you got something there. We never, I never had a more fun audition before or since, we just sat and goofed around. Yeah, I was gonna say we were on the same level humor wise but those guys are geniuses. Yeah, they are. No kidding. Yeah, they are. No kidding.
但你在办公室坐了一个小时，你肯定觉得你在那里得到了什么。我以前从来没有过比这更有趣的试镜，无论是之前还是之后，我们只是坐在那儿瞎扯。对，我是说我们在幽默感上在同一水平线上，但那帮家伙是天才。是的，他们是。绝对的。是的，他们是。绝对的。
Yeah, but I can't imagine, well, yes, I can't imagine. I was gonna say that, did they let you contribute once you got in there and really started, I mean, that character is so specific, John. I mean, what an incredible job you did with that character. I have to assume that you augmented that dialogue a little bit or no? They're pretty specific, right?
是的，但我无法想象，好吧，是的，我能想象。我本来想说的是，一旦你加入进去并真正开始干，他们会让你参与创作吗？约翰，那个角色太具体了。我是说，你把那个角色演得太不可思议了。我得假设你对那段台词做了一些即兴发挥或者没有？他们的剧本非常具体，对吧？
I wouldn't know how to augment any better than they wrote it. We had rehearsal time on Lebowski. So by the time we shot, we were in pretty good shape with the dialogue and that's why a lot of people asked me if it was improvised. Just so conversational. Because we were facile with it.
如果让我来改，我都不知道怎么才能改得比他们写得更好。《谋杀绿脚趾》（Lebowski）的时候我们有排练时间。所以到我们拍摄的时候，我们的台词已经磨合得非常好了，这就是为什么很多人问我是不是即兴发挥的。只是听起来很像日常对话。因为我们对台词非常熟练。
What was that process like making that? I mean, the big Lebowski obviously is held up as one of the all-time greats. One of my favorites. It was just lovely. And it's just a great time, great hang. Do you remember reading that script the first time? Yeah.
制作那部电影的过程是怎样的？我是说，《谋杀绿脚趾》显然被公认为影史最佳之一。我最喜欢的电影之一。那段经历太美妙了。那是一段极好的时光，大家相处得很愉快。你还记得第一次读那个剧本时的情景吗？记得。
And did you know Steve and Jeff beforehand? No. Or was the chemistry just great luck? Great luck. Yeah. Isn't that wild? Kismet, man. And everybody hit it off.
你之前认识斯蒂夫（Steve）和杰夫（Jeff）吗？不认识。还是说化学反应纯粹靠运气？纯粹靠运气。对。是不是很疯狂？命运的安排，老兄。而且大家一拍即合。
So you read that, they send you that script and you're like what? You're like, holy shit. Did they write it for you? I'll bet they did. Oh, Lebowski, yeah. Yeah. That and Barton Fink.
所以你读了剧本，他们把剧本发给你，你的反应是什么？你当时的反应是，操。他们是为你量身定做的吗？我敢打赌他们是。哦，《谋杀绿脚趾》，是的。对。还有《巴顿·芬克》（Barton Fink）。
Yeah. And the last one I did for him. Which was the last one? Inside Lewin Davis. Yeah. Beautiful movie. A little bit more of a serious turn. Yeah, it was cool.
对。以及我为他们拍的最后一部电影。哪一部是最后一部？《醉乡民谣》（Inside Llewyn Davis）。对。美丽的电影。稍微严肃了一些的转型。对，很酷。
Yeah. Talk about that. I mean, think about the breadth of characters that you played with them at the helm as writer-directors and all with such different tones, too. What is that shift like, that dynamic working with them on films that have such a hugely vastly different tone to them. They're such film fans and magpies for popular culture that just throw in and everything and it works. They've got great ears for people's dialogue, for human speech. Will worked with Barry Sonnenfeld.
是的。聊聊这个。我是说，想想你和作为编剧兼导演的他们合作过的大量不同角色，而且所有角色的基调都如此大相径庭。那种转变是怎样的，在基调如此迥异的电影中与他们合作，动态关系是怎样的。他们是超级电影迷，就像流行文化的喜鹊一样，能把各种元素杂糅在一起，而且效果出奇的好。他们对人们的对话、人类的语言有着极好的乐感。威尔和巴里·索南菲尔德（Barry Sonnenfeld）合作过。
I was about to bring up Barry. I love Barry. We've had him on this show and I've been friends with Barry for a number of years and I worked with him a couple of times and he's, you obviously worked with him on a bunch of great films, Jay, you mentioned, I mean, and also very different. Raising Arizona, Miller's Crossing were both Barry films.
我正要提起巴里。我爱巴里。我们邀请过他上这个节目，我和巴里是多年的朋友，我和他合作过好几次，他——你们显然和他在很多伟大的电影中合作过，杰，你提到了，我是说，而且也非常不同。《抚养亚利桑那》、《米勒的十字路口》（Miller's Crossing）都是巴里的电影。
Again, so totally different from the script and the way they looked. Yeah. And fantastic. He talked about his first, what was his first? Oh, well, Blood Simple. Yeah, Blood Simple. Blood Simple was the first.
同样，剧本和视觉呈现方式都完全不同。对。而且太棒了。他谈到他的第一部作品，他的第一部是什么？哦，对了，《血迷宫》（Blood Simple）。对，《血迷宫》。《血迷宫》是第一部。
Yeah. And he claims that they hired him because he had a camera. Yeah, I believe that. But back then they were broke and they would just know what they wanted and they'd invent ways to do it. Like these guys from the 20s, they just if they had a problem they'd solve it and strap a camera on a board and run with it. Did you see that progression? Have you seen that evolution? Because you've been with them for so long, and they might say the same about you, the evolution of them as filmmakers from Raising Arizona to Lou and Dave,
对。而他声称他们雇他是因为他有一台摄像机。对，我相信这一点。但那时候他们身无分文，他们只知道自己想要什么，然后就会发明实现的方法。就像20年代的那些电影人一样，如果他们遇到问题，他们就会解决问题，把摄像机绑在木板上扛着就跑。你见过这种演变吗？你见过这种进化吗？因为你和他们合作了这么久，他们可能对你也有同感，从《抚养亚利桑那》到《醉乡民谣》，他们作为电影制片人的演变，
I mean, it must be pretty significant. Yeah, more of a shortcut than anything else. The more experience they get, the easier it gets. The less they need to say, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah. John, moving forward in your career and your life, do you still have the fire in your belly that you had when you were a kid to just kind of pursue,
那一定相当显著。对，比起别的，这更像是一种走捷径。经验越丰富，事情就越简单。他们需要说的话就越少，你知道吗？对，对，对。约翰，展望你未来的职业生涯和生活，你心中是否依然燃烧着年轻时那种去追求、
keep going, challenging yourself? It's much different now. Yeah, in what way? Because I feel like I'm still learning. The last couple of years have been goofy for me because I've been trying to be good and it doesn't work that way. Planning things way too much and at the root of that
继续前进、挑战自我的火焰？现在很不一样了。对，在什么方面？因为我觉得我还在学习。过去几年对我来说有点傻里傻气的，因为我一直在试图表现得很好，但事情根本不该这么运作。把事情计划得太周详了，而这根源于
was the fear of losing trust in myself. So I overcompensated by working way too hard and I've just kind of come out of that in the last year or so and it's, and there's so much to learn. Yeah, how did you manage to come out of that? Frankly, having a nervous breakdown. No, it was bad with everything.
对失去自我信任的恐惧。所以我通过过度工作来过度补偿，我大约在过去一年左右才从那种状态中走出来，而且，有太多东西要学了。是的，你是怎么设法走出那种状态的？坦白说，经历了一次精神崩溃。不，一切都变得很糟糕。
And it just, finally, yeah, it just purged out of me. I went to the therapist one day, and then for the rest of the day it was horrible. Nothing worked. I woke up the next day and I'm, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. This is a sheriff's dance to run my head, but it just felt a lot better.
然后它终于，是的，它从我体内宣泄出去了。有一天我去看心理医生，接下来的整天都糟透了。什么都不对劲。第二天我醒来，然后我开始，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。虽然我脑子里还在胡思乱想，但感觉好多了。
You gotta be relaxed when you do stuff, and open and listen. Do you find that, I'm finding that the older I get, the smarter I get, the smarter I get, the smarter we all get, but with the added intelligence or observational skills, comes the burden of trying to manage all of the new stuff that you're absorbing and learning.
你做事时必须放松，保持开放并学会倾听。你有没有发现——我发现我越老越聪明，我们所有人都越来越聪明，但随之而来的不断增长的智慧或观察力，也带来了试图管理你正在吸收和学习的所有新事物的负担。
Yeah, there's something brilliant about staying ignorant. Yeah, it just keeps complicating stuff and making things more dynamic and more fun, but it's more of a challenge and you gotta keep up. You have to be ready to listen to yourself. You have to be relaxed. Hard. For me, that was the key.
对，保持无知有一种绝妙的好处。对，它只会把事情搞得更复杂，让事情变得更动态、更有趣，但这是一种更大的挑战，你必须跟上节奏。你必须准备好倾听你自己的声音。你必须放松。很难。对我来说，这就是关键。
I already know this stuff. And that's the one thing I didn't trust myself about. I didn't make it to Stella Adler. I didn't trust myself about. I didn't make it to Stella Adler, I didn't make it to Udahagan. I got into the studio, but I've never been there. I felt I didn't have a base for everything. And it finally dawned on me, I know this stuff. And I've been doing this for 50 years. It's like, you know it. And it's there if you listen for it,
我本来就知道这些东西。而这就是我对自己缺乏信任的地方。我没能进斯特拉·阿德勒（Stella Adler）学校。我对自己缺乏信任，我没能进乌塔·哈根的学校。我虽然进了演员工作室，但我从来没真正融入过。我觉得我做的一切都没有根基。然后我终于恍然大悟，我懂这些东西。我已经干了50年了。这就好像，你心里其实有数。只要你肯倾听，它就在那里。
if you let it come to you, it's boom. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Did it start to feel like maybe you weren't, like you weren't doing anything, and then you realized, well, that's because I'm just natural at it and I do know all this stuff,
如果你顺其自然，那就炸了。是啊。是啊，是啊。你会不会开始觉得，也许你没有，就好像你什么都没做，然后你意识到，哦，那是因为我天生就会这个，而且我确实懂所有这些，
and I've just found sometimes if I'm so comfortable in a character, I can sometimes feel like, oh, I'm just kind of phoning this in, I'm just walking this through, and then you feel like, oh, then maybe I should play this scene a little, I should act a little harder, you know? And then it feels like, well, now I'm really working today. But then you kind of might, you might watch playback
而且我有时发现，如果我对一个角色太游刃有余，有时就会觉得，哦，我只是在应付了事，我只是在走过场，然后你就会觉得，哦，那也许我应该把这场戏演得稍微，我应该再努力演一点，你知道吗？然后就会觉得，好吧，今天我可真是在卖力工作了。但接着你可能就会，你可能会看回放
or just even hear your own voice and be like, no, God, this isn't working, this feels like shit. And then you go back to just doing it normally and it's like, no, that's great, that's fine. I know this stuff and you just happen to be natural at it. I wonder if that's how like athletes feel when they just, they're just playing, they're just in it, you know? That's what it is, just playing.
或者甚至只是听到自己的声音，就会想：不，天哪，这根本行不通，这感觉太烂了。然后你又回到了正常的状态，心想：不，这很好，这样就行。我懂这些，而且你刚好对它很擅长。我在想，运动员们在比赛时、在状态中时，是不是也是这种感觉？就是那种感觉，纯粹的投入。
Yeah. And listening. Do you find as you're changing as a person that it changes the kinds of roles that you look to do since what we do is kind of an exercise in personal exploration we happen to get paid for? I don't know. I've been doing the same role for the last,
是的。还有聆听。你有没有发现，随着你作为一个人的改变，这也会改变你想要去尝试的角色类型？因为我们所做的事，某种程度上就是一场个人探索的练习，而我们恰好能因此拿到报酬？我不知道。我过去这，
same two roles. No, you haven't. For the last like four or five years. Yeah. And I haven't really had much of a chance to do everything else. Cause you've been doing the Connors, you're talking about the Connors. Yeah, the Connors and the righteous gemstones.
相同的两个角色。不，你没有。在过去四五年里。是的。而且我真的没有太多机会去尝试其他所有事情。因为你一直在演《康纳一家》，你指的是《康纳一家》。对，《康纳一家》和《宝石珍家中》。
Yeah, it's also, John, it's also wild to hear you talk about whatever, whether I've read about stuff that you've been struggling with and you're so nice to be open about your journey, just being more comfortable in your own skin and getting to know yourself as Jason said, as we get older, that it's always so surprising and it's never not surprising to look at you,
是的，还有，约翰，听到你谈论那些事情，无论是关于我读到的你一直在挣扎的事情，还是你如此坦率地展露心路历程，这都让我觉得很棒。正如杰森所说，随着我们变老，能够更自在地做自己，去了解自己，这总是让人惊讶，而且看着你时，这种惊讶从未停止，
somebody I've always admired, and is like, wow, that's such a cool career, I'd love to have his career. Like, amazing actor, everything he does, to hear somebody like you speak publicly about whatever your issue is, whatever you're going through, is really kind of eye-opening,
一个我一直以来都很崇拜的人，心想：哇，那是多么酷的一段职业生涯啊，我也好想拥有他那样的职业生涯。作为一个出色的演员，他所做的一切，听到像你这样的人公开谈论你的任何困扰、你正在经历的事情，真的让人有一种大开眼界的感觉，
because from over here, it's like, oh, he's got this career of a lifetime. And it's always so surprising and it shouldn't be. And it's also so helpful to me. Because the same goes for me as far as my admiration for you. But it makes me feel a lot better about all the human feelings I have that are sometimes challenging.
因为从我们这边看过去，会觉得：哦，他拥有令人艳羡的职业生涯。而且这总是让人感到意外，尽管本不该如此。这也对我大有帮助。因为我对你的崇拜也是一样的。但这让我对内心的那些有时颇具挑战的人类情感感觉好多了。
It's like, you know, it's silly that we all need a reminder that everybody's human, but it's really nice to hear. So thank you for sharing all this. My pleasure. It's just kind of to help myself and maybe help somebody else. But yeah, I've been clean about 16 years now. And that's great. The last 16 years I've had clean about 16 years now.
这就好像，你知道的，我们所有人都需要被提醒每个人都是凡人，这听起来有点傻，但听了真的很受触动。所以谢谢你分享这一切。不客气。这其实既是为了帮我自己，也许也能帮到别人。不过是的，我到现在已经戒酒大约16年了。那太棒了。在过去的16年里，我……我现在已经戒酒大约16年了。
And the last 16 years I've had to grow a lot into my normal age and it's been a lot, but I'm glad I did it. Oh, that's great. John, you know, the last time I saw you, I was gonna say this when you first popped on on the show today, but the last time I saw you was Saturday Night Live when I hosted in 2001
在过去的16年里，我必须在心理上成熟很多，才能配得上我现在的实际年龄，这经历了很多，但我很高兴我做到了。哦，太棒了。约翰，你知道的，我上次见你时——我本来想在你今天刚上节目时就说的——但我上次见你还是在2001年我主持《周六夜现场》的时候，
at the after party, you came, everybody was partying, and you walked in and pulled your pants down and walked all the way across the entire room and everybody was dying laughing. I was like, is that John Goodman with his pants down? I don't remember that. That's longer than 16 years ago. I'm cursed with a bad memory like that.
在庆功派对上，你来了，大家都在狂欢，然后你走进来，把裤子一脱，从整个房间的这一头走到了那一头，所有人都笑得前仰后合。我当时想：那真的是约翰·古德曼，而且他把裤子脱了吗？我记不清了。那是16年多前的事了。我这人有个毛病，记性很差。
I will remember stuff like that, but this one. Yeah, no, believe me, the 300 people that were there remember it. Oh my God. It was great. So you're gonna- You were so good on that show too. There's gonna be a lot of stuff missing
我会记住那种事情，但这一件……对，不，相信我，当时在场的300个人都记得。天哪。太棒了。所以你要……你在那期节目里也表现得太棒了。会有很多事情被遗漏
from your autobiography because of your ability to recall some of the stuff. I get the same problem. I get to pad it with blank pages. Draw your own conclusions and Cliffy the Clown. We'll be right back. We're brought to you in part by ZipRecruiter. Many of us have heard the famous quote by Abraham Lincoln that says,
在你的自传里，因为你记起某些事情的能力有限。我也有同样的问题。我得用空白页来凑数。得出你自己的结论吧，还有小丑克利菲。我们马上回来。本节目部分内容由 ZipRecruiter 赞助播出。我们很多人都听过亚伯拉罕·林肯的那句名言：
Good things come to those who wait. But that's only part of the quote. The full quote is, Good things come to those who wait, but only the things left by those who hustle. Well, if you're a business owner and want the best people on your team, the same applies. Thankfully, ZipRecruiter puts the hustle in your hiring, so you find qualified candidates fast.
美好的事物属于耐心等待的人。但那只是名言的一部分。完整的话是：美好的事物属于耐心等待的人，但留下的只有奋斗者争取来的东西。好吧，如果你是一位企业老板，想要招募团队中最优秀的人才，同样的道理也适用。谢天谢地，ZipRecruiter 能为你的招聘注入奋斗动力，让你迅速找到合格的候选人。
And now you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash SmartList. If you happen to see a candidate who'd be perfect for your role, ZipRecruiter can help make sure you're front and center. All you need to do is use ZipRecruiter's pre-written invite to apply message to connect with your favorites ASAP. It's that easy. Let ZipRecruiter give you the hiring hustle you need. See why four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Just go to ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis to try it for free. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash smartlis.
现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/SmartList 上免费试用它。如果你恰好看到某个非常适合你职位的候选人，ZipRecruiter 可以帮你确保处于最显眼的位置。你所需要做的，就是使用 ZipRecruiter 预先写好的邀请申请信息，尽快与你心仪的人选取得联系。就是这么简单。让 ZipRecruiter 为你提供所需的招聘动力。看看为什么五分之四在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主能在第一天内就招到优质候选人。只需访问 ziprecruiter.com/smartlis 即可免费试用。再次提醒，网址是 ziprecruiter.com/smartlis。
ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. Support comes from Netflix, presenting the new limited series Baby Reindeer. Have you heard of it? Of course you have. It's the global hit that's hooked audiences worldwide with its singular, surprising, and spellbinding story. The New York Times raves it's astonishing. Variety calls it a rare gem on television and GQ says it's as powerful as TV can get. Richard Gad, Jessica Gunning, and Nav Amow give riveting performances in this deeply personal series that legendary author Stephen King declares is one of the best things I've ever seen. Baby Reindeer for your Emmy consideration in all categories.
ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。本节目由 Netflix 倾情支持，为您呈献全新限定剧集《驯鹿宝贝》。你听说过吗？你当然听过。这是一部全球热门剧集，凭借其独一无二、令人惊叹且引人入胜的故事，迷住了全球观众。《纽约时报》盛赞其“令人惊叹”，《综艺》杂志称其为“电视界一颗罕见的明珠”，《GQ》则评价它“具有电视所能达到的最强冲击力”。理查德·加德、杰西卡·古宁和纳瓦·莫乌在这部极具个人色彩的剧集中奉献了引人入胜的表演，传奇作家斯蒂芬·金甚至称其为“我这辈子看过最好的作品之一”。请在各大奖项中为《驯鹿宝贝》的艾美奖提名投上宝贵的一票。
We get support from State Farm. Nothing feels better than a personal win from finishing a home DIY project, hitting a workout PR, or even just taking your car in for that oil change. If you define it as a win, it calls for a celebration. And who's cheering right beside you? State Farm. With the State Farm Personal Price Plan, you can create an affordable price just for you
我们得到了 State Farm 的支持。没有什么比完成一个家居DIY项目、在健身时打破个人纪录，甚至只是把车送去换机油更能带来个人成就感了。只要你认为这是一次胜利，那就值得庆祝。而谁会在你身边为你欢呼呢？State Farm。通过 State Farm 个人价格方案，你可以打造一个专属于你的实惠价格，
when you bundle home and auto. So celebrate by breaking out the confetti and those happy dance moves. Talk to a State Farm agent today to learn how you can bundle and save with the Personal Price Plan. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Prices are based on rating plans that vary by state. Coverage options are selected by the customer.
只需将房屋和汽车保险打包组合。所以，快拿出彩带和开心的舞步来庆祝吧。今天就联系 State Farm 的代理人，了解如何通过个人价格方案组合保险并节省开支。就像一个好邻居，State Farm 一直在你身边。价格基于因州而异的评级方案。保障选项由客户自主选择。
Availability, amount of discounts and savings, and eligibility vary by state. This episode is brought to you in part by Robinhood. Is your money working as hard as it could be for your future? It's nice to be in the driver's seat and have autonomy when making investments, which is easy to do with Robin Hood Robin Hood was founded a decade ago and has changed the future of finance offering stock trading IRAs and many more products to over 23 million funded customers with Robin Hood It's simple to make investments towards your future goals. Whatever those may be Maybe you want to work towards investing for your family's future
可用性、折扣和省钱金额以及投保资格因州而异。本集部分内容由 Robinhood 赞助播出。你的资金在为你的未来做最充分的努力吗？在进行投资时能够掌握主动权并拥有自主权感觉真好，而使用 Robin Hood 就能轻松做到这一点。Robin Hood 创立于十年前，改变了金融的未来，为超过 2300 万有资金注入的客户提供股票交易、IRA 个人退休账户以及更多产品。有了 Robin Hood，为你的未来目标进行投资变得很简单。无论这些目标是什么，也许你想为家人的未来投资努力，
Maybe a vacation this summer or visiting every baseball stadium in the country We all have some bucket list items to cross off and Robin Hood has tools to help us pursue them. You know, it's pretty cool to have the power of investment and trading on your phone in the palm of your hand. It sounds really, really cool. As far as long-term investing, a small amount invested now could make a big difference 30 years down the road. Take your financial future by the reins, download the app, or visit robinhood.com to learn more. Investing involves risk and loss of principal is possible. Returns are not guaranteed. Robinhood Financial LLC member SIPC
也许是计划今夏的度假，或是去遍全国的每一座棒球场。我们每个人都有一些愿望清单上的项目等待去实现，而 Robin Hood 拥有能帮助我们实现这些目标的工具。你知道的，把投资和交易的力量掌握在手机里、握在手心里的感觉真的很酷。这听起来真的非常非常酷。就长期投资而言，现在投入的一小笔钱在 30 年后可能会产生巨大的差异。掌握好你财务未来的方向盘，下载应用程序，或访问 robinhood.com 了解更多信息。投资有风险，本金可能会亏损。收益不作保证。Robinhood Financial LLC 是 SIPC 成员，
is a registered broker dealer. And now back to the show. I remember seeing you on SNL. It was, I think, Amy, my ex-wife's first year on the show and you hosted. And I just stayed very far away. I remember seeing you at the after party and being like, oh my God.
是一家注册经纪交易商。现在回到节目中。我记得在《周六夜现场》上见过你。那是，我想，埃米——我前妻——上节目的第一年，你担任主持。而我当时离得远远的。我记得在庆功派对上看到你，心想：哦，天哪。
Yeah, I hit it off with her from Jump. Yeah, yeah. It just, hers, she and Seth wrote a bit and we did it. I thought it was a brilliant bit. But I just did, I really dug her. Yeah, she's cool. It made me feel welcome. Well, you, yeah, yeah, and you were so good.
对，我从一开始就和她很对脾气。对，对，对。就是，她、她和塞斯写了一个小品，然后我们演了。我觉得那是一个绝妙的小品。但我就是，我真的很喜欢她。对，她很酷。这让我感到很受欢迎。嗯，你，对，对，而且你真的很擅长。
You had such a facility for that. You could have been an all-time great cast member for sure. Yeah, I don't know how to do improv, but. No, but you don't need to know. I auditioned for it in 1980 when everybody quit. You did? And they brought the new cast on. No way. Did you really?
你在这方面太有天赋了。你绝对可以成为史上最伟大的演员阵容之一。对，我不会即兴表演，但是……不，但你不需要会。我在 1980 年每个人都辞职时去试镜过。真的吗？他们换了新演员阵容。不会吧？你真的去过吗？
Yeah. You know who got it? Laurie Metcalf. Oh, wow. But she was, I don't think she ever went on air. I don't know what happened, but she was one of the people they picked. Oh, wow. I didn't know that. Oh, it was horrible. It was open calls, and they had guys walking around in Blues Brothers costumes, like, by the score.
对。你知道谁入选了吗？劳里·梅特卡夫。哦，哇。但她，我觉得她从来没有上过电视。我不知道发生了什么，但她是他们挑选的人选之一。哦，哇。我不知道这件事。哦，太可怕了。那是公开试镜，有成群结队的人穿着《福禄双霸天》的服装走来走去。
It was a hideous dream. No way. A desperation flop sweat. Oh, fuck, man. So would that have been a job that you would have really, really loved, being a part of that cast? That was my... That used to be my favorite thing
那真是一场可怕的噩梦。不会吧？散发着绝望的冷汗。哦，见鬼，伙计。那么，这会是你非常非常热爱的工作吗，成为那个演员阵容的一员？那是我的……那曾是我最喜欢的事情
to do every year. I'd get so goddamn scared and just hit the door and walk onto the floor. It was great, man. I was a big fan of the national lampoon when I was in college. And when I saw a lot of the writing staff from Saturday Night Live, I was really intrigued. And I saw a lot of the writing staff from Saturday Night Live,
每年都要做。我会吓得要死，然后一鼓作气冲出门，走上舞台。太棒了，伙计。我上大学时是《国家讽刺杂志》的超级粉丝。当我看到《周六夜现场》的许多编剧时，我真的非常着迷。而且当我看到《周六夜现场》的许多编剧时，
I was really intrigued. And it was a hit to me. I remember parties used to stop when it had come on and people would watch television. For sure. Oh yeah, that's a good point. It was a big deal. Who were your big kind of idols when you were a kid,
我真的非常着迷。这对我来说是个轰动。我记得以前只要节目一开播，派对就会停下来，人们都会看电视。确实。哦，对，说得好。这可是一件大事。当你还是个孩子的时候，
when you went and did acting or comedy or anything? Like who were you like? Well, I'm almost ashamed to say Brando. Why, that's great. Yeah, I know a lot of people my age will say that. He just never seen anything like him. And I didn't really pay that much attention to movies. I liked him.
当你开始涉足表演、喜剧或任何这方面的事情时，你的大偶像有哪些？就像你把谁视作榜样？嗯，我甚至有点羞于启齿——白兰度。为什么，这很棒啊。对，我知道很多我这个年纪的人都会这么说。你从来没见过像他那样的人。而且我其实并没有那么关注电影。我喜欢他。
What was the thing that was distractingly different about him per the style that was around right then? He looked like he was making it up. Right. And it's this 19, he had a 1950, 51, looked more like a guy, incredibly good looking guy that walked off the street. Right, so the style was much more sort of...
当时围绕在他身边的表演风格中，有什么东西让他显得与众不同、令人分心？他看起来就像是现编的。没错。那是19、他有种1950年、51年的感觉，更像是一个人，一个难以置信好看的、从街上走过来的人。没错，所以当时的风格更偏向于……
It was presentational. Broad, yeah, presentational back before that, right? It was a much bigger thing. It's a style. He and Montgomery Clift and all those guys, right? He got more naturalistic. Montgomery Clift was another icebreaker. He was one of my idols too, even though he's a little before my time
是表现主义的。夸张的，是的，在那之前是表现主义的风格，对吧？那是一个宏大得多的东西。那是一种风格。他和蒙哥马利·克利夫特以及所有那些人，对吧？他变得更趋向自然主义了。蒙哥马利·克利夫特是另一个破冰者。他也是我的偶像之一，尽管他比我早了一点代际……
I he was one of the guys I loved him I'm pretty old. Yeah, I think people are slightly the kids today Are kind of sliding away from that that stuff that I was raised with the Group theater everything was based from that, and the Stanislavskiites, and then the sects that developed among the acting teachers. It seems like people are getting away from that now. But did you wanna get into comedy where you're like, okay, I'm gonna be, I think that I have,
我，他是那种我爱戴的人，我挺老了。对，我觉得人们有点——现在的孩子们有点背离了我成长时接触的东西了，组剧团（Group Theater）的一切都是基于那个，还有斯坦islavski（斯坦尼斯拉夫斯基）学派，然后表演老师之间又发展出了各种流派。现在人们似乎在远离那些。不过你当年是想演喜剧吗？当时你是觉得，好吧，我打算，我觉得我有，
I'm quite adept at comedy. Did you know that? Was that something that you were like? I was good at comedy in the classroom and when I thought it was still cute to mug. Right. Yeah. No, it has to be necessarily really structured
我很擅长喜剧。你知道吗？那是你当时心里想的吗？我在课堂上挺擅长喜剧的，当我觉得扮鬼脸还挺可爱的时候。对。对，不，喜剧必须得有真正结构化的
comedy play, as opposed to like improv, but there are rules there too and it has its own structure. And it can be terribly hard, but when it's easy, man, it flies and there's nothing like it. I have to, John, a lot of the times on this show. I thought Sean was gonna say, I have to go, guys. I thought this was Sean's words. I'm going right now.
喜剧剧本，而不是像即兴表演那样，但即兴表演也有规则，它有自己的结构。那可能会难得要命，但当它顺的时候，天哪，进展神速，无可比拟。我不得不，约翰，在这档节目里很多时候。我以为肖恩要说，我得走了，伙计们。我以为这是肖恩说的话。我现在就要走了。
No, I have to. Wait a minute, almost there. I am presently going. It's warm. No, I have to ask if you have any tragic theater stories like mine falling on the table at the dinner table, only because I love them because they're so shocking to me.
不，我得。等一下，快了。我目前正在走。天气真暖和。不，我得问问你有没有什么悲剧性的剧场故事，就像我在饭桌上摔倒在餐桌上那样，这纯粹是因为我太喜欢听了，它们对我有种巨大的冲击。
The worst thing that ever happened to me was in, well, two things happened in the show. I was doing a musical in 1985 on Broadway and I was doing it for a while. Which one, do you remember? Yeah, Big River. And I was supposed to come out and surprise my son Huckleberry Finn.
我经历过最糟糕的事是在，好吧，演出中发生过两件事。1985年我在百老汇演一部音乐剧，演了一段时间。哪一部，你还记得吗？对，《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》（Big River）。我本该出场给我儿子哈克贝利·费恩一个惊喜。
And before, I was standing behind this flat, waiting to go on, and I couldn't remember my first line. And I panicked. Oh God. And I panicked. And I just wouldn't come, and I was, the queue was there, and I was gonna step out and say, ladies and gentlemen, I'm so sorry, I can't.
而在那之前，我站在一个布景板后面，等着上场，结果我记不起我的第一句台词了。我恐慌了。哦天哪。我恐慌了。台词就是想不起来，然后，Cue点到了，我本打算走出去说，女士们先生们，非常抱歉，我不能……
And the line popped into my head. But that happened for four nights straight. Yeah, yeah. Wait, did the line pop in your head once you stepped onto stage or before you did? Yeah, as soon as I opened my mouth. Isn't that amazing how that went? Isn't it amazing how that happened?
然后台词突然闪回我脑子里了。但那种情况连续四天每天都发生。对，对。等等，台词是你一踏上舞台时才想起来的，还是之前就想起来了？对，我一开口它就出来了。是不是很神奇？难道不觉得这事很神奇吗？
Yeah. And it's wild. It's right there, and I don't know why it happened. And the second was, my son was supposed to hit me, Huck Finn was supposed to hit me in the jaw with a stool, a three-legged stool, and one night I forgot to... Turn.
对。太疯狂了。台词就在那儿，我不知道为什么会这样。第二件事是，我儿子本该打我，哈克贝利·费恩本该用一个凳子打我的下巴，一个三条腿的凳子，有一天我忘了……转身。
I forgot to put my hand up and throw my head back, and I caught it, and it drove my jaw back into my head, it knocked me out, and I got up and finished the show. No, I finished my scene and I had to go down the street to the hospital. No way. Wow. You didn't have a broken jaw, did you?
我忘了把手举起来，把头往后仰，结果结结实实挨了一下，把我的下巴直接撞回了脑子里，我当场被打晕了，但我爬起来演完了整场。不，我演完了那一场，然后不得不顺着街走到医院去。不会吧。哇。你的下巴没骨折吧？
No. No, no. No, but it was touch and go for about five days there when I didn't show up. Understudy started getting stretched out. Yeah. Let him have it for a while. Yeah, this was a performance after, you just took like 10 feet, stepped 10 feet away.
没有。没有，没有。没有，不过有那么四五天情况悬得很，我都没去。替补演员都开始做热身准备了。对。让他演了一会儿。对，这是演出之后的事，你只是走开了10英尺，退开了10英尺。
So it was really far away. No, but I understand that thing about the line. I was doing Hairspray Live on NBC. This is like five years ago, eight years ago, I remember. And it's live in front of the whole country and I'm playing Mr. Pinky or something like that. And it's that sensation and I rehearsed and rehearsed and now I'm behind the door,
所以离得很远。不过，我懂台词那种情况。我当时在NBC直播《发胶星梦直播秀》（Hairspray Live）。大概是五年前，八年前，我记得。那是全美直播，我在里面演平基先生（Mr. Pinky）之类角色。那种感觉，我彩排了一遍又一遍，现在我站在门后，
it's live in front of the country and it's a big deal. And I opened the doors and I had the sensation, I think it was Marty Short and Harvey Fierstein or something like that, and I said in my head, am I supposed to be here right now? I think I may have entered too early, all in the span of half of a second. Oh yeah, you could put a whole dictionary
全国观众都在看直播，这可是件大事。我推开门，然后有了那种感觉，搭档好像是马丁·肖特（Martin Short）和哈维·费尔斯坦（Harvey Fierstein）之类的人，我在心里想，我这会儿该在这儿吗？我觉得我可能进场太早了，所有这些都在半秒钟之内闪过。哦对，你可以在那半秒钟里
in that half a second. Totally, so I'm sitting there and I turn to him and I mouth the first line instead of singing it and it looks like the sound was cut out. And so I was. That's perfect. That's horrible. Is that a technical glitch at the top of my number?
塞进整整一本字典。完全是这样，所以我站在那儿，我转向他，对着他的嘴型只动嘴不出声地念了第一台词，而不是唱出来，看起来就像是声音被切断了。于是我就……太完美了。太可怕了。那是我的重头戏一开场就出了技术故障吗？
What a fucking disaster. It was a disaster, it was a panic inside was so unbelievable that then I started singing the second line, it was just awful. It was awful. It was terrible. How did it turn out? We also had, I think the first or second preview
真是个天大的灾难。简直是灾难，内心的惊恐简直难以置信，以至于我开始唱第二句台词时，整个人糟透了。糟透了。太糟糕了。后来怎么样了？我们大概在五六年前
of the front page did about five or six years ago. And there were guys that came in, sat in the front row, put their drinks on the stage and their feet up there, and then one guy got up and started going, I love you John Goodman, I love you John Goodman, I love, and I go, I'll just not say anything. Please make, and he got up, he walked out of the theater. That was a little frightening.
演过《头版新闻》（The Front Page）的第一场或第二场预演。当时有几个家伙走进来，坐在第一排，把饮料放在舞台上，还把脚翘在上面，接着其中一个家伙站起来开始喊：“我爱你，约翰·戈德曼！我爱你，约翰·戈德曼！我爱——”然后我想，我还是什么也别说了吧。求求你们……然后他站起来，走出了剧场。那场面有点吓人。
No kidding. There was two girls who can do this show called An Act of God and there's these two girls that were bombed out of it. No, I don't think so, this time. Yeah, no, I saw it, I saw it, the Amundsen. Oh, that's right. They were bombed out of their minds
可不是嘛。当时有两个女孩来看一部叫《上帝的作为》（An Act of God）的剧，那两个女孩喝得酩酊大醉。不，我不认为，这次不是。对，不，我看见了，我看见了，阿蒙森。哦，对。她们喝得烂醉如泥，
and from the second I walked out, they were screaming like, I love you, I love the second I walked out, they were screaming like, I love you, oh my God, I love you, in front of everybody. Everybody was quiet. Chuck. Yeah, exactly. Screaming, and so I was like, they're not only drunk, I think they're on drugs or something.
从我走上台的那一秒起，她们就在尖叫，比如“我爱你，我爱——”我一走上台，她们就在当着所有人的面尖叫“我爱你，天哪，我爱你”。全场鸦雀无声。查克。对，没错。尖叫个不停，所以我想，她们不仅是喝醉了，我觉得她们还嗑药了什么的。
And I think I've told this story on the show before. But they were so gone, in my head, while I'm talking in my head, I'm like, I think I have to stop the show. And so I went, I go, excuse me a second, I walked off stage, this is on Broadway, told the stage manager, you gotta get the two girls out of there.
我想我以前在节目里也讲过这个故事。但她们实在醉得太厉害了，在我脑子里，当我一边说话时，我脑子里在想：我觉得我得停下演出。于是我走过去，我说：“不好意思一下，”我走下舞台——这是在百老汇，——告诉舞台经理：“你得把那两个女孩弄出去。”
They're not moving, they're clapping and laughing at every word. Wait, wasn't this the one man show? Yes, this is a one man show. So you walked off the stage. Walked off stage. Left stage empty. Left stage, yeah, left the stage empty. The security guards came down, removed them,
“她们坐立不安，对每一个字都在鼓掌和大笑。”等等，这不是个单人秀吗？对，这是个单人秀。所以你走下了舞台。走下了舞台。把舞台留空了。把舞台留空，对，把舞台留空。保安走了过来，把她们带走了，
the whole audience clapped. I walked on and I said, and that's the power of God. Because I was playing God. And I just kept going. Oh, that's pretty good. But it's awful, and people just don't know how to behave in the theater, is the moral of the story. because I was playing God. And I just kept going. But it's awful and people just don't know how to behave in the theater, is the moral of the story.
全场观众都鼓掌了。我走上台说：“看，这就是上帝的力量。”因为我当时在扮演上帝。然后我接着演下去了。哦，那挺不错的。但这种事太糟了，这个故事的道德教训就是，人们根本不知道在剧场里该怎么举止，因为我当时在扮演上帝。我接着演下去了。但这太糟了，人们根本不知道在剧场里该怎么举止，这就是故事的道德教训。
It's getting worse too. It is getting worse. It is getting worse. Oh man, John Goodman, we have taken up way too much of your time, man. Just honestly from a far, from very afar, just been such an admirer and just a complete fan of yours.
而且现在这种现象越来越严重了。确实越来越严重了。确实越来越严重了。天哪，约翰·戈德曼，我们占用了你太多时间了，老兄。真的，从很远很远的地方，作为一个长久以来的崇拜者和彻头彻尾的粉丝。
I am a huge fan of you guys as well. Great, yeah, okay, I'm gonna cut it short there, but thank you. I really, really appreciate you hanging out with us for an hour. I was terrified at the beginning of this. Oh man. Really? You guys are so good.
我也是你们几位的超级粉丝。太棒了，好，那我就简短收尾，不过谢谢你们。真的很感激你们花了一个小时陪我们闲聊。我一开始的时候还挺害怕的。天哪。真的吗？你们太棒了。
Again, that just makes us feel incredible that we're even on your radar, let alone, you know. So, thank you. Ding-dongs, you know. Ding-dongs with a wifi connection. Jason's in New York with a wifi connection in a rented apartment, he's just starting a job. Sean's in Hancock Park facing away from his TV. I can hear somebody vacuuming above me. I'm like, what, this starting a job. Sean's in Hancock Park, facing away from his TV.
再次重申，能进入你们的视线就让我们觉得不可思议了，更不用说……所以，谢谢你们。这群笨蛋，你知道的。连着Wi-Fi的笨蛋。杰森在纽约的出租公寓里连着Wi-Fi，他刚开始一份工作。肖恩在汉考克公园（Hancock Park），背对着电视。我能听到上面有人在用吸尘器打扫卫生。我当时想，什么，这刚开始一份工作。肖恩在汉考克公园，背对着电视。
I can hear somebody vacuuming above me. I'm like, what? This is a joke. We're a bunch of clowns. So thank you for doing that. The great John Goodman. Thank you, my friend. What an honor.
我能听到上面有人在用吸尘器打扫卫生。我当时想，什么？这简直是个笑话。我们就是一帮小丑。所以谢谢你们能来。伟大的约翰·戈德曼。谢谢你，我的朋友。这真是太荣幸了。
Thank you for the invite, man. It's been wonderful. Anytime. Thank you. Thanks, pal. That was fantastic. Thank you, John, very much. Adios. Thank you, thank you. Thanks, Patrick. That was fantastic. Thank you, John, very much. That was John Goodman.
谢谢邀请，老兄。这太美妙了。随时奉陪。谢谢。谢谢啦，老兄。太棒了。非常感谢你，约翰。再见。谢谢，谢谢。谢谢，帕特里克。太棒了。非常感谢你，约翰。那是约翰·戈德曼。
That's John Goodman. The great, the gold standard, as I said. The gold standard. And maybe the best, most classical name in the history of all names. I wonder, what is his middle name? Is it equally classic, an American, like a Frank or something like that? John Frank Goodman. Steven actually, I think it's Steven. Yeah, there you go, that works.
那是约翰·戈德曼。伟大的人物，正如我所说，是黄金标准。黄金标准。而且也许是所有名字里最经典、最正统的名字。我在想，他的中间名是什么？也一样那么经典、那么美国化吗，比如弗兰克（Frank）之类的？约翰·弗兰克·戈德曼。其实是史蒂芬（Steven），我觉得是史蒂芬。对，这就对了，这名字行。
Is it really? John Steven Goodman. That was a fantastic get there, Will. I set myself up for that and got a real beat down. He's just. How about he's killing it on the Connors too? Isn't the Connors still running like? We didn't even get a chance, I wanna get a, so he does the Roseanne. He's just... How about he's killing it on the Conners too? Isn't the Conners still running like... We didn't even get a chance.
真的吗？约翰·史蒂芬·戈德曼。那一期访谈请得太棒了，威尔。我刚才自己挖坑给自己跳，结果被狠狠打脸了。他简直是……他在《康纳一家》（The Connors）里的表现也很炸裂，不是吗？《康纳一家》还在播吧？我们甚至都没机会，我想聊聊……他在《罗珊娜》（Roseanne）里的表现……他在《康纳一家》里的表现也很炸裂，不是吗？《康纳一家》还在播吧？我们甚至都没机会。
I wanna get to the... So he does the Roseanne. He's doing two television series right now. They do it like 12 years. Roseanne's like 263 episodes or something, right? And then he goes, and now they've done almost 100 episodes of the Conners. Unbelievable.
我想聊到……所以他演了《罗珊娜》。他现在同时在拍两部电视剧。他们拍了大概12年。《罗珊娜》拍了大约263集左右，对吧？然后他说，现在他们又拍了将近100集《康纳一家》。难以置信。
Yeah, and in that time, he's made like 10 movies with the Coen brothers and amongst others You know and he's just been in like the guy's just done it all I'm not gonna cry. I'm sorry. I just had a little bit of gas. It's just gas But like this is to be him and to sustain all that through all like I don't know whatever he's it just means you're great Yeah, he's just got it. He is great, and he has been great for his whole career, and has stayed employed his whole career. I guarantee you this, I bet you if you go back
对，在那期间，他和科恩兄弟合作拍了大约10部电影，除此之外还有……你知道的，他几乎把所有类型的角色都尝试过了。我可不打算哭。对不起。我只是有点胀气。纯粹是胀气。但就像这样，成为他这样的人，并且把这一切坚持下来，经历了所有的……我不知道，不管他经历了什么，这就意味着你真的很伟大。对，他就是有这种实力。他真的很伟大，而且整个职业生涯都一直这么伟大，戏约不断。我敢向你保证，
and you find some of those early commercials, you watch them and you're like, this guy's great. By the way, I have seen those early commercials, when he was really young. I think it was like a burger commercial or something, and you're like, oh yeah, that guy's great. And he's great, right? But Revenge of the Nerds was like one of the first four or five things he did.
如果你去翻翻他早期拍的那些广告，你看了之后就会觉得：这家伙太棒了。顺便说一句，我还真看过他那些很早期的广告，当时他真的很年轻。好像是个汉堡广告之类的，你看了就会想：哦，对，这家伙太棒了。他真的很棒，对吧？但《疯狂夏令营》（Revenge of the Nerds）是他早期拍的四五部作品之一。
And he was like, you watch that movie and you go, oh, you feel like that guy had been around forever. Exactly, he feels iconic. He feels iconic and it's one of his first films. And you're like, oh, that's John Goodman. I don't know why I remember the one line from Roseanne. I don't know why I remember this. They were on vacation and they got in an argument
你看了那部电影就会觉得，哦，你会觉得这家伙已经在演艺圈待了地老天荒了。没错，他自带偶像光环。他自带偶像光环，而且这还是他早期的电影之一。你会想，哦，那是约翰·戈德曼。我不知道为什么我一直记得《罗珊娜》里的某一句台词。我不知道为什么我能记住这个。他们当时在度假，然后吵了一架，
and they were like in the Bahamas or something. And Roseanne goes, you know what, Dan? We should have gone on separate vacations. I go to the Bahamas and you go to hell. And I was like, oh my God. And I was like, I can't believe they just said that. I was so young, I was like, I can't believe they said that on TV.
他们好像去了巴哈马群岛什么的。然后罗珊娜说：“你知道吗，丹？我们当时应该分开度假的。我回巴哈马，你下地狱。”当时我就想：哦天哪。我就想：我简直不敢相信他们居然说出这种话。我当时太年轻了，心想：我简直不敢相信他们在电视上说这种话。
That's a great light. That was produced by the great Tom Warner. And produced by the great, and the Connors still produced by the great Tom Warner, our friend and chairman of Liverpool Football Club. And pretty strong aid handicap, maybe? Is he? I'm trying to think. He's a good golfer. He's not to be underestimated.
这台词太棒了。那是由伟大的汤姆·沃纳（Tom Warner）制作的。由伟大的……而且《康纳一家》现在依然由伟大的汤姆·沃纳制作，他是我们的朋友兼利物浦足球俱乐部（Liverpool Football Club）的主席。而且他的高尔夫球让杆数还挺厉害的吧？是吗？让我想想。他是个出色的高尔夫球手。不容小觑。
I wanted to say happy birthday to our buddy Billy Hogan over there at Liverpool Football Club. I think we missed it. Did you want to sing to him right now? Because Sean and I would love to sign off first, if that's okay. Oh, before I do it? If you're gonna be singing. Yeah, yeah, yeah, just before you start singing. But you know I always do like a classic,
我想祝我们在利物浦足球俱乐部的好朋友比利·霍根（Billy Hogan）生日快乐。我想我们错过了。你现在想为他唱首歌吗？因为如果可以的话，肖恩和我想先挂断。哦，在我唱之前？如果你要唱歌的话。对，对，对，就在你开始唱歌之前。但你知道我总是喜欢来个经典的，
it's sort of like an homage to Marilyn Monroe. I always do that. Real classic. No, don't lift up your sweatpants for him. Yeah. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Lift up your sweatpants for him. Yeah. Ah.
有点像是在向玛丽莲·梦露（Marilyn Monroe）致敬。我总是这么干。非常经典。不，别为了他掀起你的运动裤。对。哈，哈，哈，哈。为了他掀起你的运动裤。对。啊。
Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. Ah. So I'm trying to think up a by. Oh.
啊。啊。啊。啊。啊。所以我得想一个“再见”（buy）。哦。
Let me think about that one. Are we supposed to, you know what, here's what I would like. And it was, two things. The first one was confirmed, or re-suggested by the great Justin Theroux earlier today. We need to have some live questions from the fans, or at least read a question online.
让我想想那个。我们是不是应该——你知道吗，我想要这个。有两件事。第一件是今天早些时候由伟大的贾斯汀·塞洛克斯（Justin Theroux）确认或重新提出的。我们需要回答一些粉丝的现场提问，或者至少在网上读一个问题。
We are gonna maybe do something like that, but go ahead. I would like also in that same folder some suggestions for buys from our listeners. I'm sure they would come up with these, why don't they ever use this word? First of do have I do have a buy that I was I was getting to but I want to say two things about I think that you're right JB I think that's a good idea yeah and but I will also say this we are not taking fucking creative suggestions from fucking Justin Theroux.
我们可能会做类似的事情，不过你继续。我还希望在同一个文件夹里能有听众给我们提供的“买买买”（buys）建议。我确信他们会想出这些，他们为什么从来不用这个词呢？首先，我确实有一个我正要说但我想说两件事……我觉得你是对的，JB，我觉得这是个好主意。对，但我还要说的是：我们才不接受贾斯汀·塞洛克斯那混蛋的创意建议呢。
You know what you're right. So this guy. Every time I see him he says the same you know what? You're right. So fucking keep him... Every time I say he says the same, you know what you guys ought to do? I'm like, oh, shut the fuck up. I'll tell you how to cut your sleeves off. How about this? Yeah. Yeah. Fuck you, Justin! Into the nose, out through the mouth.
你知道吗，你说得对。所以这家伙。每次我见到他，他都说同样的话，你知道吗？你说得对。所以赶紧让他……每次我说话，他都说同样的话，“你知道你们该怎么做吗？”我心里想：哦，给老子闭嘴吧。我来教教你怎么把袖子剪掉。这样行吗？对。对。去你的，贾斯汀！吸气，呼气。
Yeah, fuck you, Thoreau! You fucking fuck! Bye. On three, no, on three, fuck you, Thoreau. Are you ready? One, two, three. Fuck you, bro! Anyway guys, I did get some new bye-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee-ee- SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barberko. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus
对，去你的，塞洛克斯！你这个混蛋！再见。数到三，不，数到三，去你的，塞洛克斯。准备好了吗？一，二，三。去你的，兄弟！不管怎样，伙计们，我确实搞到了一些新的“再见”……SmartLess是一档100%有机且由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫（Rob Armjarve）和贝内特·巴尔韦科（Bennett Barberko）手工制作的播客。如果你喜欢SmartLess，现在就可以通过Wondry App或苹果播客加入Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告的内容。
in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. Scammers are best known for living the high life until they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit once they're finally caught. I'm Saatchi Cole. And I'm Sarah Hagge. And we're the host of Scamfluencers, a weekly podcast from Wondery that takes you along the twists and turns of some of the most infamous scams of all time, the impact on victims and what's left once the facade falls away. We've covered stories like a Shark Tank certified entrepreneur who left the show with
Prime会员可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上无广告收听。在离开之前，请前往 Wondry.com/survey 填写简短问卷，告诉我们关于您的一些信息。骗子们最出名的往往是过着穷奢极欲的生活，直到有一天他们东窗事发，被迫换上手铐和橙色囚服。我是萨奇·科尔（Saatchi Cole）。我是莎拉·哈格（Sarah Hagge）。我们是Wondry每周播客《骗术名流》（Scamfluencers）的主持人，我们将带您深入了解历史上一些最臭名昭著的骗局的跌宕起伏，了解它们对受害者造成的影响，以及当虚假的光环褪去后留下了什么。我们报道过各种故事，比如一位获得过“创智赢家”（Shark Tank）认证的企业家，他带着
an investment but soon faced mounting bills, an active lawsuit filed by Larry King, and no real product to push. He then began to prey on vulnerable women instead, selling the idea of a future together while stealing from them behind their backs. To the infamous scams of Real Housewives stars like Teresa Giudice, what should have proven to be a major downfall only seemed to solidify her place in the Real Housewives Hall of Fame. Follow Scamfluencers on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Scamfluencers early and ad-free right now on Wondry+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
投资离开了节目，但很快就面临着如雪片般飞来的账单、由拉里·金（Larry King）提起的一起进行中的诉讼，却根本没有什么拿得出手的实际产品。于是他转而将魔爪伸向了脆弱的女性，向她们兜售共度未来的幻想，同时却在背后偷走她们的钱财。还有诸如《粉红佳丽》（Real Housewives）明星特蕾莎·朱迪斯（Teresa Giudice）等人的臭名昭著的骗局，原本应该证明是她演艺生涯的重大滑铁卢，却似乎反而巩固了她在《粉红佳丽》名人堂中的地位。请在Wondry App或您获取播客的任何地方关注《骗术名流》。您现在就可以在Wondry+上提前且无广告地收听《骗术名流》。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。